the session is another talk on social
networks this time on misinformation
persuasion and news media by chinchia
hi everyone I'm glad to be here and meet
you all at summons Institute oh so today
today I'm gonna quick intro to myself
and my PhD work on misinformation
participation and news media on social
networks
um this scissors investigates people's
behavior of news consumption in
environment with real and false
information
uh
happens
okay it's about me I obtained my PhD at
MIT
um
so my current research interests are lie
in Game Theory strategic communication
design for social system and HCI on
platforms and I'm currently a postdoc at
Microsoft and also a program research
fellow in the graph limits program
so with the Advent of social media
platforms online news business is
boosted and according to a survey that
um 70 of a thousand Americans consume
news near social media they attentively
receive information on a platform they
share digital content and sometimes they
actively attend to some news media on
social platforms for information that is
not easy easily accessible to the public
such as the the war in Ukraine so I will
talk about more details about these
three parts
so
um there is a lot of information on
social media but turned out like much
information of both uh were inaccurate
so Ellicott and against go present some
evidence about the exposure to fake news
prior to the 2016 election and
versatility at all in 2018 they
empirically showed that those new tend
to spread wider than real news on
Twitter
enjoy Uganda find that no structural
difference in newspaper can be largely
explained by the transmission rate of
news between peers that is to say that
it seems like people tend to share false
news with higher probability than real
needs
so what is the motivation behind the new
sharing so the New York Times actually
point out some possible reasons so
sometimes we want to inform others we
want to provide some content identify
ourselves to some group uh to strengthen
the relationships and feel engaged in
the discussion but here here I use
another angle that people share
information because they want to
persuade other they want to change
others beliefs so that you know their
actions can be aligned with my objective
so here
I cut this province to the angles of our
strategic complication
and about the news media what roles are
they playing so the the book 11 elements
of Journalism point out some like
principles like you should report the
truth you should verify and uh you know
the news media should be independent
from other buyers
but I think we already uh very familiar
with this that news media are usually
biased with their own political gender
and can't score at all actually point
out two major ways that news media buys
their report
so sometimes they ignore the events they
don't want to disclose to you the
information or sometimes they just
briefly like over a very high level
picture about the events without
providing details to you
uh moreover Michelle at all showed that
uh news consumers tend to choose the
news media with the same ideology so I
think people here are very familiar with
the term that we I coded us homophily so
you want to attend to the news media
with the online ideology
so here we see these two phenomena
um first is false news triggers logic
has paid and um but what is and why and
how like misinformation is provided so
what is the role of news credibility in
new sharing and how is it related to
population characteristics another
problem is about the homopoly we
observed in news media about that market
so why people choose like a line
ideology
and what are the concerns when they
select the news media for news and how
you know maybe the stream is and centers
make the different choices and how we
like rationalize these choices
so I can't do these two problems uh
using again theoretical Frameworks so I
in my models I say oh what if people are
rational and strategic and they're more
main motive for sharing and disposing
news is to participate others so here I
propose the following framework is a
general framework for two or five papers
so I consider a large population of
Agents with heterogeneous individual
beliefs on some
underlying state of the world and then
people have this preference for the
alignment of others action movies my own
belief so I I want you to take the
action that I think is right so I
persuade by feeding others new
information so I use information to
change your belief about the state
and in the end people need to take a
binary action like the election so we
represent the two ideological means
so I will briefly talk about the models
the two models I have uh I won't provide
to my many technical details but give
you a very broad picture of my model so
my first work is with Amir and my
advisor Ali
so again so this is a large population
and people have their own
um individual heterogeneous belief it is
their private information but we assume
that there is a common knowledge that I
know the distribution of the possible
but I don't directly observe people's uh
belief on the state
so here I consider this news that is a
real number
um and then I use this term credibility
data between 0 to 1 to measure the
credibility of the names
and what does it mean let's see
um
so the one means fully credible and zero
means like this news is without any
information
so what is the expectation on the state
if you haven't received any news you
just preserve your prior belief on the
state new eye but if you receive the
news you do the convex combination
between the news and your prior belief
using this credibility of the needs so
you see that if the news is fully
credible then you totally believe the
the says the news that is
so this is a broke picture the timeline
of my model so people are connected via
the rented social networks there's a
following follower Network
and then I use the random Network model
I think people are familiar with this
and with the personal degree
distribution
and then when some agents see the news
they decide whether to share or not and
they strategically thinking like they
need to influence their followers to
leave but they also consider okay my
followers may receive the news from
others so there is a strategic concern
here
um I I won't detail the the Strategic
constant here and then eventually people
just you know they choose whether left
or right
so these are the main results of our
paper so basically we prioritize this
new thread that is endogenous at
equilibrium
and then we show that when network is
sufficiently dense like very connected
the less credible news can spread wider
than uh fully credible news so basically
there is a limit on the network
connections like Beyond which
uh the less credible news case required
and then we further showed that okay if
we consider population with a polarized
uh opinions
then we see that the strong polarization
and can actually decrease the limit
meaning that the less credible news can
spread wide
um in a wide range of Networks
but when we consider this perspective
diversity
it can actually have a monotone effect
on this limit so
so people will say the convention no
question would be like oh if you
increase the diversity you can help
inhibit the spread of misinformation but
here we show that it is not necessary
correct
uh I think I kind of a runoff time I
would be very quick
so uh let me jump just jump into this
subscription model
so basically people want to choose the
lab or write
and then there's some news it can
actually be false uh and then it will be
passed to the news media so the Fox News
and they receive the news or not
and then if they do receive the news
they first decide whether to verify at
some cost
and then they decide okay should I
disclose this information to my uh
readers were not
and then subscribers will update the
police and take the action based on
whether they see the news if they
receive the news they just update
if they don't receive the news they also
need to strategically think okay maybe
the Fox News will see and conceal the
message from me and then bill is also
updating process here
so let me give you a very interesting
result we actually showed that uh the
centuries
have this anti-hemophily Behavior
meaning that if I'm the right Republican
but I'm a Centrist and I would actually
seek the information from the left
knitting part because I'm afraid of some
information that is useful for me but
you know the fast news will sometimes
conceal some left in the news from me
but I think that is useful for me but
the left knitting part will reveal that
information so I that's why I have this
concern and I will seek information from
left and in part but
interestingly that which uh the
extremist will actually have this
homophobic Behavior because they kind of
have the same that a line objective
which there are they align a news media
because
um
if I know this train is Republican I
know that only the very
True News but that is love learning uh
will change my decision and also that
will change false news decision false
news will definitely verify that kind of
information for me so this is like when
the instruments have the Align objective
so they seek the information from the
line news media
so this is some research directions uh
that can be extended based on my status
work but recently I'm very interested in
hybrid work so I'm happy to discuss any
collaboration in this new area
um yeah
thank you thank you so much
thanks for the talk any questions
oh thank you for the talk uh very nice
um I was wondering if you have done any
testings against the like of the real
data you collected on social platforms
or if you if you if so then can you
comment on how I gave a few comments on
how yesterday yeah good yeah so here my
thesis work is like purely theoretical
uh and then yeah
um
my advisor I mean my PhD advisor stood
has some thought about should we run the
experiments because I think this to test
this model we need to run the experiment
instead of using the color uh existent
data to better data
but yeah I'm
I'm open to that uh directions
any more questions
do you find that there is an asymmetry
in other words does one side prefer more
outrageous news than the other side or
the more unbelievable news and how does
that affect your statistics
so let me clarify of course no you mean
but I find theoretical evidence that
people want to find extremist
information
right well the The Stranger more
outrageous news does it tend to go to
one side referred by one side versus the
other
um yeah I'm not sure if I understand
correctly but here in my model I
actually have this Legend and there is a
variation here that we show that if you
see some extreme news that is opposite
from you
you may think that is likely to be false
news and then you will not update your
belief to the opposite side
so here but when it comes to some
opportunity of verification you will
definitely want people to verify the
extreme and opposite news for me and for
you
but if you just see that news and you
think that is likely can be false or
true then you will think okay that is
false and I don't believe that news well
I'm getting my impression is that the
right yes side of the political Spectrum
tends to prefer the more outrageous
unbelievable news and then the left side
or is that how does do you take that
into account in in your in you know in
your data or in your system yes yes yes
as I said so here actually we consider
like various belief systems and in one
case is that let's say about a
Republican and I see some news that is
aligned with my ideology
uh is anti I believe that that is more
likely to be true and I will buy that
information but if that information is
on the left leaning part and I will
think okay you know just based on my
prior belief I would think that is false
news and I will not buy that information
but here because I know that news media
will still have the option to verify the
news so I will rely on that verification
for me otherwise if you know if there is
no verification in this model
there there's some possibility that as a
republican I would just believe uh the
right mini news while I don't buy the
left in the news because I think that is
likely to be false that is
let's take further questions in the
Break
um so thanks to all the speakers of the
session and we will now have a half an
hour break and reconvene at 11 30.
foreign